so you've seen this before you're going
to see it again
all across the country so legislation
pending in the state house in delaware
would allow children to get abortions or
sex changes
without notifying their parents so their
parents insurance would pay for this but
the parents don't have a right to know
democrats back this bill of course and
say flat out abortion and gender
transition related services
are covered
so
your kids can have abortions and sex
changes
and democratic politicians in delaware
and many other states don't want you to
know about it
so
if there was ever an effort to destroy
the nuclear family this obvious we're
not aware of what it might be terry
shilling is the president of the
american principles project and joins us
tonight to assess terry thanks so much
for coming on
you know the parents relationship with
his or her children is sacrosanct like
politicians aren't allowed to get in the
middle of that you would think
and yet democrats in delaware and many
other states are trying to destroy that
relationship
who's fighting back against this
well there are parents primarily there
that are fighting back against this
tucker and they're being organized
primarily at the local level there are
efforts at the national level my
organization american principles project
is building what we call the nra for
families but ultimately this is going to
be about parents taking back control of
their kids education
directly
we have to make these people pay a
political price when they hurt our
families tucker you said it best this is
really about abolishing the family
the progressives would say that they're
liberating children from the parental uh
constraints and the parental oppression
and the patriarchy really they're
destroying them
their goal is to liberate these children
to achieve full equity and full equality
and they will achieve that we'll just
all be equally miserable and and
terrible and sad
it will destroy the country it'll
destroy the economy and it'll destroy us
as individuals if we allow
these states to do this and it's really
important tucker to pay attention to
delaware they are on the cutting edge
they're they were the first state in the
nation to codify roe they were the first
state in the nation to redefine
parenthood that was in 2009 well before
gay marriage passed so we have to pay
attention because what happens in
delaware ends up spreading to a lot of
other states
yeah i mean they hate their fathers
that's the basis of their politics i get
it but that does not give them a right
to mess with our kids they always want
to mess with your kids what you know why
not pick on adults why do they have to
take your children brainwash them cancel
your
family ties to your own kids your
parental authority like why can't we
just draw a line at our children i
wonder
well it's because children are very
vulnerable to ideas right i mean if you
look at the ecosystem that the
progressives have created it's a
full-fledged ecosystem and it's not i i
the story is much bigger than just what
the legislation will do to insurance
companies and the explanation benefits
what no one's talking about is that
these schools in delaware all have
school-based health clinics and when
parents sign up you know they sign those
permission slips and begin a year you
know signing away a bunch of consent
forms they sign a consent form that
allows these school-based health clinics
to treat their children
and they give away their rights to stop
them and i think most parents think it's
going to be ibuprofen or anything like
that but it's much worse um but kids are
susceptible to these ideas i mean
especially these little kids with the
sex ed classes and the gender identity
classes
um they they're they still believe in
santa claus right
it's more than a million americans have
pulled their kids out of public schools
in the last year there's gonna be a
collapse of school people running away
from this stuff it's too it's too scary
it's too threatening and i appreciate
the work that you're doing in this terry
thanks so much subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight